you got married often notice in that run
married this spring yeah I got married
in March are you sorry
yeah definitely I feel like we got
married and then went on an awesome
honeymoon and then I just jumped right
into work so I would definitely advise
any late Brides to be like give yourself
like a little bit more time to like but
it is still so nice I say husband so
much it's obnoxious like glitter oh when
we got married my husband we literally
we're so dorky we changed I was so
excited Center I married for I was like
I'm changing your name to husband
husband and then I it's like a red heart
emoji I'm not in that one your balls
it's like husband redheart husband red
hearts it's bad yeah that's amazing yeah
let's talk about music what what are
like your songs that inspire you oh my
gosh do you think so many genres I do
that as well so I was just kidding you
want you know how hard that is
oh my god I would say that the first
song for me would be this castle on a
cloud which is the song I said in lame
is yeah because I'd never sang before in
my life and then I went on an open call
for lame is in my hometown saying that
song and got the part and was on
Broadway two weeks later working so that
song I also love any like anything on
Jagged Little Pill that was the first
record I ever bought perfect
and then don't rain on my parade because
one of my favorite oh really I love
funny girl me too
it was my like get in line I do and then
I don't think I'm like just saying this
but since you've been gone for me
[Applause]
why auntie Linux is definitely what do
you have a lot of analytic stuff and
then he was like any good kid like she
gives a cute little gift bag to wine and
I know it's my favorite things so yes I
love wine and vinyl any little why any
Linux I'd probably say Bonnie rain love
me like a man and I'm talking about the
live version the record version is all
right the live version is jam and then
I'd say I never loved a man by Aretha
Franklin oh yeah yeah
[Applause]
[Laughter]
I love female or female singer - I
really do everyone's like what do you
listen to what kind of music do you like
I'm like any girls like any girl any
girl I like powerful women but yeah but
I mean today country yes any kind of
female vocalist I'm like give it to me
yes sorry boys tell us about your new
album it's my it's my first Christmas
record it's coming out it's called
Christmas in the city and I'm from New
York born and raised in the city and I
moved out here ten years ago and the one
thing I've really missed are my
Christmases in New York and I go home
every holiday beautiful it's the best
and so this is all about that time of
year that reminds me of family and being
with friends and being where I was you
know born and raised and I just picked
all of my favorite Christmas songs it
was just it's just amazing I will not
stop talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this